good evening my friends so let's start
with the story that everyone is talking
about the sun and talk tv's exclusive
interview with rebecca vardy on the
wagatha christie saga but my question is
how on earth can anyone keep up with the
twists and the turns so this old man
will try and put it straight in your
head so it all started with this woman
this is colleen rooney and her private
instagram now if you're not sure you
don't know colleen is married to
england's record goal scorer wayne
rooney now while she didn't mind the
likes of you and me seeing her post
there were things she wanted to keep
between her nearest and her dearest but
these stories will mysteriously leak to
the newspaper so to nail her suspect
colleen rooney made her instagram
stories only visible to one person it
was this woman rebecca vardy fellow wag
and wife of another england striker
jamie now colleen come back here she
then fabricated events happening in her
life post them on her account and waited
to see if they would hit the tabloids
and lo and behold the invented tales
were published she then sent out that
tweet it's rebecca varney's account
[Music]
vardy responded poetically with the
following i'm not being funny love but i
don't need the money so the argument
continued in court there was a right
libel trial bought by her sorry rebecca
vardy colleen this is her cayman thank
you came out on top leaving her rebecca
devastated
and three million quid poorer
i didn't do anything wrong i didn't do
it you know there's
lots of people that probably have given
stories i was
enemy number one and target number one
her team say that they did give you
opportunities to withdraw essentially to
stop this from going as far as it did
you can't
enter into settlement negotiations with
people that are being aggressive
so joining me now is model and colleen
rooney's best mate danielle lloyd how
are you i'm good what a day what a day
what a week i know
i i wanted to ask you actually to start
what i said to somebody earlier why do
you think this story that started on
instagram between
two wags with everything that's going on
in the world the the people who are
suffering all this money all this hassle
why has it captured the imagination of
the public people just love drama they
just love it and
really it could have all been avoided
and it could have just been we wouldn't
be talking about it now the whole court
case didn't happen so when you when you
look at it right and we've heard
rebecca's side today read it in the sun
seen it on talk tv um
you know you are a friend of color you
found yourself in the middle of the saga
there were messages look at her face
what's that message is from rebecca and
former agent caroline watts this is the
woman who lost her phone in the sea uh
describing you as a nasty [ __ ]
i know
that's completely wrong isn't it you're
lovely we've met before um apparently
the court was also told that rebecca
threatened to leak stories about you
after the horrible miscarriages yeah
that's true and that was obviously
something like really traumatic that i
obviously didn't want to think about
again and i think it's really horrible
for someone to obviously be trying to
leak stories about something so vile
when you see rebecca vardy on that
interview emotional
saying i will never give up protesting
my innocence until i'm blue in the face
i'm innocent i'm this and i'm that
and she was going to leak a story about
you you say
at such a traumatic time
what do you make of that tonight
i think the lines are very blurred i
think you know she's obviously sitting
there protesting her innocence but these
stories came from her account and
you know there was
whatsapp messages saying that she would
be prepared to leak stories on other
people so why would she not leak them on
colleen you said and talk to you earlier
in the week daniel you said that you
felt like justice has been done yeah how
would you describe rebecca vardy
oh gosh
can i say um
i think
i don't think she's telling the truth
i think you know she's trying to save
face and
and she could have prevented all this
you know i think obviously
it's not nice to be
um targeted by trolls i think that's
horrible and it shouldn't be happening
but um you know there's things the
messages you can't get away from
this this is the point and we'll talk
about um colleen in a moment and and the
toll that all of this is taken but i
never understood
everybody has an opinion right yeah
for me it was just looking in the eyes
and i could see it straight away but
what i don't understand is why she
continued and still continues i mean the
judge said that vardy clearly knew of
condoned or actively encouraged the
leaking of personal information and that
that basically her her testimony was was
not believable that is damning yeah
exactly but apparently the judge was
wrong and she didn't have a clue let's
talk about colleen your mate um and i've
met colleen and rooney and wayne several
times and i like them both and and i'm
just being straight about that um
what's the toll been on colleen
i think it's been really stressful and i
think that's why this whole
why she put that text out because
she'd been through hell for two years
not knowing who's to trust and i think
like going through something like that
must be traumatic you know not knowing
what friends to trust whether it was
family
it's been really hard so i'm glad that
she's found out cleverly who
where i came from colleen has also said
that she would have she would have
finished this she doesn't she didn't
want the spectacle that it became and
and
and there is only one person that pushed
for that because rebecca brought the
libel case yeah she did and you know
what
there's one thing that i know about
colleen she doesn't like the limelight
she doesn't want to be
a big celebrity she wants to just be a
mom and you know i'm going to i'm going
to say this because i've met her a
couple of times and the last time was in
an airport and you know you hear about
all these wags and all the money and all
the stuff you know she's got
there's four kids running around all
over the place she's doing all the stuff
her mum and dad are there wayne's on the
phone obviously in the corner and and
she's a normal girl and you know a lot
of people will criticize colleen rooney
and say oh you've stayed with him
despite all the the things that have
happened she loves that man she loves
her her family is the most important
thing to her exactly and you think about
what this did to the kids as well right
yeah like obviously on both sides like
rebecca's and colleen's kids like it's
just not been nice for any of them i'm
sure they've been getting bullied in
school and stuff like that like because
kids can be cruel
um
but and social media are abuse to them
both to the kids that just on goes as
well right exactly like the court case
never had to happen
no
this interview that rebecca did tonight
didn't have to happen
it could have all been prevented what
would you say to rebecca vardy after
that tonight and after the last and and
after everything what would you say to
her
honestly like
there was part of that interview that i
just sat there and laughed like it was
it was hard to watch it was actually
quite a cringe if you were her would you
now give up the ghost and go away and
and try and get on with your life
quietly or like colleen's done you know
she hasn't done an interview or she's
just said like let's get on with our
lives it's over it's done
and just move on and
be happy
i'll try well she hasn't because she's
allegedly i should say allegedly
otherwise i get into trouble signed up
for a documentary and i wonder in all of
this what jamie makes of this apart from
the bill three million quid apparently
the portuguese villa might need to go
there'll be people who can't afford to
pay their you know the electricity bills
going oh bless they've got to get rid of
the villa but it just didn't seem to
make sense did it no there was a lot of
things in there you know that she said
like oh i would never leak a story on
someone but in text messages you've
said that you would be prepared to she
said she didn't need the money and but
then there was a a text in there that
said i want paying for this one now
there's a lot of blade lines so blurred
line with the agent as well i know she's
had mental health issues so we can't get
into too much detail but that phone in
the sea i mean honestly that was like
you'd love to get that phone wouldn't
you um just to finish you are a good
friend of colleen um how is she doing
no i haven't actually spoken to her and
even if i did i don't think i would say
because i think this whole thing is
about privacy and i think obviously i
respect colleen's privacy and
silence is golden though isn't it it is
keep your powder dry daniel lloyd always
a pleasure great mum great to have you
on thank you
you